kubernetes is great for running a lot of
different containers at scale but those
containers contain code that is
constantly changing
and when there's a lot of change there's
risk how can you reduce this risk
involved with dirty software deployments
to kubernetes
hi my name is barbara moros and i'm a
customer engineer at google
today we'll talk about how to reduce
this risk using the release pattern of
canary deployments and introduce the
ways you can put this into practice in
gk
[Music]
when releasing new code there are
different deployment strategies that can
look like canary deployments but are in
practice different
it's important to review this as each
has their own benefit and considerations
with a shadow strategy you deployed a
new version of the application alongside
the existing version of the application
instead of users getting responses from
this new version however requests are
instead duplicated in other words
sending mirror but ultimately synthetic
traffic to this new version
with this approach while your users may
not directly interact with the new
version you do need to manage complexity
such as ensuring actions that our
requests can kick off are item potent
and don't affect real downstream
services
a b testing is another deployment
strategy mostly used to make business
decisions you test the hypothesis by
routing a specific subset of users to a
version with new functionality you then
monitor user behavior within your app
and make the decision to promote the
version with the best results according
to your desired user behavior
with a canary version you test a new
change by deploying a new version of
your application alongside the
production version
then you split the production traffic
where a small subset of users will be
using the canary version
now you can monitor the performance of
the canary version
this test pattern mitigates some risks
of introducing new versions to
production since it allows you to
collect relevant data and potentially
early warning signs around your new
version's performance
then you can decide whether to make it
available to older users or not if the
changes are not satisfactory you can
easily roll back by redirecting traffic
to the older versions
so how does this testing pattern work in
kubernetes
let's walk through an example let's say
we have a stable version of an app
serving the entire user base exposed via
kubernetes service
then you deploy the new version of your
application which we'll call the canary
version alongside your stable deployment
except with a much smaller number of
replicas
this canary version will have the same
labels that match the selectors that the
kubernetes service uses
only a small amount of traffic will go
to the canary version as there are fewer
replicas
you might be thinking that it is best to
just compare the canary deployment
against the current production
deployment
however we recommend that you compare
the canary deployment with a baseline
that is the same version as a stable
deployment but deploy alongside the
canary with the same number of replicas
this helps alleviate any performance
advantages the existing stable replicas
may have from having been up for longer
such as warm caches
before you can promote the canary too
stable by scaling it up and tearing down
the old baseline and all stable versions
you need to determine what metrics
you'll monitor to help you make the
decision to promote the canary
this could be metrics such as response
latency or cpu usage
once the metrics collected and reviewed
are adequate by your measure you can
gradually scale up the canary version
until it is the only version running
this approach has some challenges
however
controlling the amount of traffic your
canary version gets by managing replicas
can be challenging especially if your
stable version has auto scalers involved
it's an imperative way to implement
canary rollouts how can we achieve the
same in a declarative manner
to do this in a declarative manner you
can look to utilize load balancer or
service mesh technology to directly
reference the amount of traffic you'd
like to be sent across various versions
of your application
by declaring this the load balancer or
service mesh will handle ensuring that
each person gets a specific percentage
of traffic regardless of auto scaling
that might be in place
canary deployments are a notable pattern
to adopt in gke for your workloads you
can quickly roll out new versions of
apps with the ability to test those
versions live production traffic and
roll back quickly should your users
encounter any issues
stay tuned for our next video where
we'll demonstrate how to achieve this in
decay with both of the mechanisms
discussed today
[Music]
you